Would it be alright if I told you all
about my first kiss?
(Cheers)
It sounds like it would be, alright.
So I'm from a small town
in the United States,
and I was working
at one of the local spots,
a job that required me
to be in person, a frontline job.
So I'm there, behind the counter.
The person I really like, they come in.
We have a great conversation.
And I know this,
because it ends with a kiss.
(Laughter)
Perhaps that kiss that day, though,
was the only good thing about the job.
The work itself was really, really hard.
Most frontline work is,
and you know this
if you drive for Uber or Lyft,
or if you work as a barista at Starbucks.
Today, I spend all my time
working with some
of the world's largest companies,
companies with tens of thousands
of frontline workers.
Nearly three billion of us
around the world do this work,
and it's my mission to make that job
as good as possible.
It just doesn't take much research
to realize why we need
to improve this job.
80 percent of frontline workers
faced some form of incivility in 2023,
and that's translated into anger.
40 percent of the global adult
workforce is mad at work.
Now, I'm not a psychologist,
but I can't imagine it's good
when half of the adults
are angry at their job.
And that number has doubled
from before COVID.
I just don't think
this has to be the case.
I think frontline jobs
can be great careers.
Let's talk about how to make that happen.
For me, it starts at the top.
CEOs don't know
what the frontline job is like,
and they have got
to figure it out right now.
I'm not sure if any of you have seen
the show "Undercover Boss."
It was hot, at least
in the United States, for a while.
Very simple premise --
executives leave their corner office,
they spend some time on the front line,
and they're always really,
really shocked what they find.
And you might say,
"Adriann, of course they're shocked.
It's reality TV.
It's American reality TV.
That is the best of the best."
(Laughter)
"These executives, they went
to Harvard Business School, that's HBS.
They have big offices.
They know what the job is like."
You might be shocked to find CEOs spend
just six percent of their working hours
with the front line.
They spend 70 percent
of their time in meetings.
I just don't believe
you can actually understand the job
when you spend just a few days
a year seeing it.
What I would like to see, instead --
I would like to see
a CEO spend 30 days straight --
that's just eight percent of the year,
tons of time, still, for your meetings --
30 days straight
doing one shift every single day.
And then spend only the money you make
from that shift, with no backups.
After this 30 days, ask yourself ...
"Can I make it?
Would I want this job
to be my kids' career?"
I think, through this experience,
you'll be a lot more attuned
to the problems with the job,
and you'll also, very importantly,
realize your own employees
have a lot of good ideas
on how to make the job better.
And before I talk about those ideas,
let's address the elephant
in the room for everyone.
That's pay.
Wages matter.
And it drives me crazy
that some CEOs in the Fortune 500
are making 70,000 dollars a day,
and it would take
their own employees 150 years
to make what they make in one year.
There's a word for this,
it's pay inequity,
and it's wrong, and it frustrates me.
And I could talk about this
for hours, believe me.
Afterwards, let's go talk about it.
But today, I want to share
something from our own research.
We've surveyed tens of thousands
of frontline workers around the globe.
Why do they say they quit their own job?
They say it has to do a lot more
with emotional needs
than just pay alone.
A really good example is a high desire
for some shift flexibility.
And when I bring this up
with executives, I often hear:
"Shift flexibility for frontline workers?
That can't happen.
Their job requires them to be in person.
Way too expensive."
I don't know if that's true.
One company I worked with
for a very long time,
they did some superdramatic things.
So, folks, buckle up those seat belts,
these are some crazy changes
that they made.
Hold on here.
So the first thing they did,
they gave their workers
a ten-minute buffer in the morning
so they could drop their kids off on time.
I know. Crazy, right?
My mind was blown
when this came up as an idea,
but it gets crazier.
The second thing they did,
they got rid of their point system.
Essentially, there's
an attendance-policy system
at most manufacturing plants,
still, around the world.
If you're late to work or don't show up,
you get a little check mark
by your name, like in kindergarten.
It's public, people can see this.
They said, "Let's get rid of that."
Good idea.
The last thing they did,
and this is, like, the moon-shot idea,
like, a next-gen AI sort of thing.
The thing they decided to do ...
they let their workers
end their shifts on time.
You work nine to five,
you get to leave at five.
It's crazy stuff.
Obviously, I'm kidding.
Like, this is clearly a joke.
But these small changes,
very few companies are doing that,
and the results speak for themselves.
At some of these plants,
turnover is down 50 percent.
There's a 40 percent reduction
in overtime hours,
and there's actually
more perfect attendance than ever.
Another company
we worked with for a long time,
we come in and we see people
are getting hurt a lot.
Like, physically injured on the job.
And we quickly realize
the personal protective gear
that's issued to the employees,
it's made for only one body type.
You can probably guess what body type.
It's the white male body type.
And we say, "That's not very smart,
so let's get safety gear
that fits multiple body types."
And that, along with a couple
other very small changes,
safety incidents were down 40 percent.
And when I bring
these examples to executives,
they often say,
"That makes a ton of sense.
I'm very compelled by this.
But isn't this turning into a 'If You Give
a Mouse a Cookie' situation?"
And I would say, one, like,
CEO, great reference,
incredible children's book.
Go back and read it,
if you haven't read it recently.
And two, and very importantly,
yes, it is turning into that situation.
You can give your employees
the full cookie.
I've talked to hundreds,
thousands of workers
over the last couple of years.
And what do the workers say themselves
that they need to be successful?
They say they need a clean bathroom.
They need safety gear that fits.
They need a little time to eat lunch.
And they need a living wage.
And when I talk
to executives, I often hear,
"Well, we can give A, but we can't give B.
If we give B, our business
is going to implode."
I'm sorry, if your business
is going to implode
because you provide workers, I don't know,
a clean bathroom and a living wage,
it's time to look
at your business model again.
And ...
(Cheers)
Yeah.
(Cheers and applause)
And I'm not saying this
to ding CEOs or companies,
I'm saying this because I have worked
with organizations
to change their business model.
It is very possible.
And when you make these changes,
what actually happens ...
it pays for itself.
It pays for itself in less overtime,
less turnover
and happier and much more
engaged employees.
And that's good for your people, CEO,
that's also very good for your business.
There's another thing
that matters to me a lot.
I hope it matters to all of you as well.
It's how we treat each other.
Now I'm not saying
you have to wander the world
as your own version
of the world's best optimist, Ted Lasso.
You can do that, that would be great.
More Teds in the world,
net positive for the world.
You're allowed to be mad
if a brand provides you a bad experience.
That is OK.
But before you get mad
at the worker in front of you,
I want you to ask yourself,
why did this breakdown
in experience happen?
Because I think these experiences,
they go bad from decisions
way above a worker's pay grade.
Let me talk a little bit
about how workers themselves
are mandated to treat all of us
as customers.
There are these handbooks
workers are given on day one,
and they are filled with rules
that employees must follow
to provide us good customer service.
Let me give you some examples.
At some fast-food chains,
employees are told if they see
somebody sitting by themselves
for ten minutes or so,
to go check on them.
At some retail stores,
you must solemnly --
this is written down --
solemnly swear, if someone comes
within ten feet of you,
you'll make eye contact,
you'll smile at them,
you'll ask if you can help with anything.
[One of] my favorite rules
I've seen recently,
some airlines, they mandate
how to treat your dog
as a customer on a plane.
And this includes all types of dogs --
big, small, barking, anxious.
There are rules the flight
attendants must follow.
I've seen this stuff,
I've asked workers about it.
I asked about it on Reddit
a couple of weeks ago,
and on Reddit, the front line
comes out in full force,
so go have a look after this.
The point is,
somebody took the time
to write down these rules,
and mandated the employees follow them.
We also can follow a set of rules
in what I will call
the "Handbook of Humanity."
And I know we can follow these rules.
Let me tell you why.
There's this restaurant called
the Restaurant of Mistaken Orders.
I'm not sure if you've heard of it.
It's based in Tokyo, Japan.
Almost all the employees there
have dementia.
It's a really interesting idea
in a country where one
in five or so people
will be affected by dementia
in the next couple of years.
The restaurant is trying
to raise awareness,
and I might be leading
the witness just a little bit here.
At the Restaurant of Mistaken Orders,
40 percent of the orders
are delivered incorrectly.
You get the wrong food.
(Laughter)
99 percent of people have a really good
experience at this restaurant.
The other one percent
filled out the survey wrong.
You know, the thing is,
you might say, "Adriann, obviously,
the Restaurant of Mistaken Orders,
people know the rules,
they know what to expect."
Yeah, that's true. And you know what?
The rules in the Handbook of Humanity
are also written down,
they're very clear for everyone to follow.
Rule number one --
if I have to spell it out for everyone --
and I will, don't worry,
I'm not going to leave you hanging --
Number one:
don't be a jerk.
Don't be a jerk when your specialty latte
takes a bit too long to brew,
and don't be a jerk
when your flight is delayed
and the gate agent has to tell you,
"Because of the thunderstorm" ...
No, gate agents cannot control
the weather, contrary to popular belief.
Don't be a jerk, and be a good human.
The Handbook of Humanity
holds in all of these situations.
There's one more group of people
I want to talk to you [about] today,
before I end my time.
What is my advice
for the three billion of us
that do frontline work?
What can frontline workers themselves do
to make their experience better?
I've honestly thought about this
for a very long time.
And I don't think frontline workers
need to do anything.
All I have to say to the three billion
frontline workers that show up every day,
in person, and that includes before COVID,
during COVID and even today.
All I have to say,
and all the CEOs of these companies
should be saying,
is a massive, massive "thank you."
(Cheers and applause)
You should not have to ask
for basic human decency,
comfortable working conditions
and a living wage.
And you should expect all of us,
as leaders of companies,
all of us as customers you interact with,
all of us just as basic humans ...
to do better.
And I am so confident we can do better.
Let's do better.
Thank you very much.
(Cheers and applause)